tras dejar cientos de muertos y
alrededor de 43 mil desplazados el
gobierno etíope anunció el fin de su
operación militar en la región del tigre
el primer ministro abhisit me señaló que
las fuerzas armadas tienen el control
total de meckel en la capital de la
región
me complace compartir que hemos
completado y cesado las operaciones
militares en la región de tigre nuestro
enfoque ahora estará en reconstruir la
región y brindar asistencia humanitaria
mientras la policía federal detiene la
pandilla del frente de liberación
popular de tigre con comunicaciones
rotas en tigre no se puede confirmar la
información del gobierno en contra parte
del líder regional ha dicho que sus
tropas continuarán resistiendo al
ejército nacional más el conflicto
inició el pasado 4 de noviembre cuando a
cnet nobel de paz 2019 lanzó la
operación para arrebatarle el poder al
frente de liberación del tigre que es
considerado un grupo rebelde
a su vez planeamos como tomar el control
de migueles sin ningún daño y esta tarde
lo logramos por completo la agencia de
naciones unidas para los refugiados
volvió a expresar su preocupación por
los costos de víctimas y desplazados
hacia el vecino sudán también añadió que
el gobierno debe garantizar su bienestar
y ellos han dejado todo atrás sus
parientes de su trabajo la mayoría son
agricultores y es tiempos de cosecha y
no pueden hacerlo así que han perdido
una gran fuente de sustento en tierra
freitas
y tienen miedo del conflicto pero más el
conflicto de temen a la violencia entre
comunidades por eso en el futuro será
importante que el gobierno restablezca
el avance sobre etiopía tours y estables
pistas pese a que el ejecutivo etíope
aseguró que la victoria del sábado se
logró sin herir a civiles y sin dañar el
patrimonio el frente de liberación del
tigre denunció que los bombardeos de los
últimos días han tenido como objetivo
principalmente estructuras civiles